hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels clip do
modern women want more than they deserve
let me know in the comments right now
just based on the title alone
nothing else do you guys think that
modern women want more than they deserve
or do you feel like they're asking for
the perfect amount
let me know in the comments and don't
forget to like comment and subscribe
and especially hit the subscribe button
you guys already know what i'm gonna say
i know i should do like a more
edited intro but
guys i hate editing you're supposed to
care more about the marriage and the man
and starting your life than this showing
off with your friends
but i mean i want i want certain people
what they want
[Music]
okay first initial reaction she's pretty
she's a pretty face
[Music]
hey how are you i'm well hurry
are you i'm good how old are you
26. hmm
would you rather be right have a man or
a are you ready to live with a woman
until the end of
until the end if you don't have one
what do you mean by being right though
i'm a little confused
being right being like there's part of
something called sign language
saying insults guilt and the need to be
right being right
typically means wait shame insult guilt
and the need to be right is he talking
about
this is modern women
a lot of modern women insist upon their
way
it has to be my way and we'll argue okay
so like my way for the highway type of
like
uncooperative okay disagreeable
okay back up a little bit
oh listen i'm not a size four so i'm
just saying because your face is half on
there
oh okay let me know i was fixing some
tea hold on okay
all right go ahead well i know
so the being right no being right just
means
it makes it almost impossible for you to
cooperate with a man long term
what's the longest relationship you've
ever had
26 26 a year um
how many relationships have you had that
you did not leave
like two how were you when the last one
happened
um i was like 24.
why do you leave okay so like
it was it wasn't really a relationship
it was like a situation
so in other words you can't count that
one you can't really i mean
now you can't count really you're ready
now
i mean you're engaged okay yeah
i think prior to i really count that how
long you've been engaged
um why is she on his show if she's
engaged
about a month now and how long have you
guys been together
for about five months
yeah you guys getting married that's
like that's a little soon for me is it
just me
um i want to get married november 2022
a year and a half from now uh well we
just bought a house so i need to save up
so
favorably i want a wedding
do you have any children no
so you guys are
known each other for less than six
months you're engaged
but you're not going to get married
until 2022 because you just bought a
house
and you want a wedding hey meredith
how many kids do you want to have um i
would say like three
when are you going to work after you are
pregnant with the first kid
no wait what are you going to work after
you're pregnant with the first
i'm gonna predict something if she wants
to get married in a year and a half
i bet that she doesn't really want to
marry him
child um
yes because i want that's because you
want what
because i want to like
i mean i don't mind combining with like
my child
but in the long run i would like to like
have my own business or something
in that type of like where'd you go
what's your
did you go to college yeah what's your
degree in
uh accounting what do you plan to have a
business in
you know i don't know yet i mean i'm
still young so i'm still figuring out
yeah a wife a mother three kids in the
business only
i mean doesn't have to be anything big
or and
but
whatever happens or whatever whatever
my what what's going to happen whatever
what
yeah whatever what
the back to the right i said the right
or wrong because like
i didn't hear what you said you were
breaking out we can get to that but i
didn't say whatever what
i needed for it i mean i wouldn't like
we agree like in the household is what
we're gonna do
so so back to the right or wrong
here's what it comes down to honestly
if you only have a year-long
relationship
what history do you have cooperating
with the man long term
i mean i we i eat that
say again repeat what you just said
sorry what history do you have
cooperating with a man long term
see i'm interested to see what
he tells her to do because he's also the
one that says for girls to get married
like as soon as possible basically cash
in
but with her like she doesn't have a lot
of dating history
i don't like the word corroborate oh
it's like
honestly i don't have a long record
because i haven't had anyone like come
into my life
and really
be on a level for me to cooperate now i
do
but prior to i really
why don't you like the word cooperate
it sounds like
cooperate i don't know sounds kind of
like roboticky
like a yes thing like anything that
goes kind of how is your fiancee
how old is your fiance 33
35 you got a 26 year old who doesn't
like the world cooperate
i mean weird work right like you know
it's not weird
then how are you gonna say how are you
gonna say love honor and obey
obey
love i don't obey let you get hit or
something
i think what she's saying is that
she doesn't want to be in a relationship
where it's every single thing that he
says
goes that it's somewhat of a compromise
and i don't know watching my parents
growing up
it was a compromise on some levels
your mother and father married yes
i mean it's really you say you're
engaged
i'm talking to a woman who says she's
engaged and wants to be mother and you
have a problem with cooperation and
obeying
no i mean i this is the word seems so
rich i don't have a problem with like
affecting my math
things of that nature but like the words
are just so
i don't know but
you guys are you guys have a premarital
counselor
i'm sorry what are you guys having
premarital counseling
um yeah yeah i hope so
oh yeah definitely damn i hope so
this doesn't sound good oh it sounds
horrible
it doesn't sound good
damn damn you sound kind of childish
i'm selfish really
i didn't think she was that bad
just because she didn't like the one
word
okay what i'm asking you you wanted you
wanna
a wedding i mean your mother and father
still married
yeah then the wedding you're gonna have
to be
paid for by them and whatever they can
afford is what you get
the person starting a marriage in a hole
but this is about you
it's not what you want so everything my
personal business but
this you you want it ready men don't
want weddings
yeah so again you would
instead of getting on with the business
of life you'd rather wait
to put yourself in a hole for a ceremony
and you don't want to cooperate
damn i think saturday morning it's just
the word cooperators means what it means
and if
this is this is what i mean this is why
i said being right
it is synonymous with i don't think
that's that big of a deal i'm pretty
laid back though but i don't think it's
that big of a deal that she wants to
wait
to save for a wedding not cooperative
and this
it [ __ ] with a lot of black women
because you have a rebellious
spirit i don't think i'm rebellious
like well what do you okay whatever word
you want to call it it's
disagreeable you have less than a year
track record of being with anybody i
hope you guys sit down
okay fun fact fun fact i'm someone on
the agreeable scale of taking a test
says i'm 70
agreeable and when i was younger i
literally hated that about myself
because i always felt like
i did what other people wanted to do and
sometimes i got walked all over
and then i hit a certain age and i
realized that that's the reason that
people like me
and now i don't really mind someone
because
you know just i'm just going to tell you
what i'm what i'm reading from you
is you're kind of selfish
oh okay and are you an only child
no no okay well are you used to getting
your way in the family like
are you the baby girl or something like
that i'm baby girl yes
yeah i'm spoiled yep i'm like spoiler
yeah and that's a and a spoiled rotten
woman ain't nobody it's good to nobody
it's good to nobody because sport being
spoiled as a baby girl or a daughter is
one thing i've been spoiled to a man and
a wife
that's a formula for bad things
so i would i hope y'all sit down with
somebody
prior to getting married and everything
else to figure out what's going on
because
you know almost like
he needs to get on your page
no no so if he decided
so he decided he didn't want to pay for
a wedding i'm still trying to make my
page what do you mean
but your page needs to be his page
that's the point
um but if he decided okay let's say he
decided he didn't want to have a wedding
let's just say
look that's it we're not doing this then
what
we're going to the courthouse
what do you say
i mean i would be upset because i'm
human and i'm a woman
and who doesn't want a wedding um
but you do personal within it so
don't you do well that's all i got to
say about
that lady you're on his show
and why do these women never answer
questions
you would make him pay for that [ __ ] too
call me whoever you are you need to have
counseling
just to make sure y'all on the same page
because whatever is going on with you in
this cooperate word
red flags um
just i'm just saying you come across as
kind of great kind of selfish it's about
you
it's all about me
that's what i'm getting i mean i mean
have you not heard this from anybody
before if i
okay well maybe i'm reading it wrong but
pre-marital counseling is always
advisable to make sure you're on the
same page
because uh the wedding and all that
stuff
especially after buying a home and this
that's for
you if your family can't afford it
take what you can get and take the small
ceremony
you're supposed to care more about the
marriage of the man and start your life
than this showing off with your friends
okay i mean
does that not make sense
i mean it does but i mean i
want i want certain people want they
want
[Music]
she was so hurt
okay um i thought that was an
interesting conversation
i don't think she sounded that bad until
the end but
kevin seems to read these women like
pretty quick
early on and it's probably from all this
experience doing it
let me know in the comments do you think
she's selfish or do you think her
requests are perfectly reasonable
and don't forget to subscribe talk to
you guys next time